good and everybody good afternoon thank
you everybody for coming out
wand if I go up a couple of things
obviously I see a lot of familiar faces
but also a ton of new faces thanks to
our friends over at the Ann Arbor our
group that helped to organize this
particular meeting I'd like to also
thank TD Ameritrade for offering us this
space the venue also to numb focus for
sponsoring the meetup group itself as
well as tamati us at the University of
Michigan for sponsoring the food for
those of you who are new a couple of
corn points
emergency exits there's one right over
here and then the doors that you just
came through on your right there's
stairs to head downstairs
also please provide any feedback both
pros/cons any critical feedback would be
very helpful and useful oh and
everything that we're presenting here
usually gets posted on our github page
so go check that out unless is a quick
question trying to hold it until the end
right and then remember that you're in
the board space so do clean up after
yourselves where the food was is where
the where the garbage is I recognize
that I fail to bring my code of conduct
this time but the crux of it is don't be
a jerk act professionally don't make
anybody feel uncomfortable remember that
any sort of sexist racist exclusionary
jokes are not permitted also any
anything yeah just be a good person okay
and if you see anything please let me
know too or hear anything all right
that's very important now we have an
icebreaker today hopefully you will
leave here and having met somebody
either please turn to somebody to your
left or to your right and tell them your
favorite book or maybe even your
favorite author so go ahead
[Music]
[Music]
all right welcome back thank you
thank you
[Music]
great so just a quick plug for this one
the Dean of science anybody by show of
hands anybody here used or have used a
played with collaboratory out of google
so if you've ever interacted with
jupiter notebook essentially it's a
jupiter notebook but on the Google
platform there is a new announcement
about collaboratory which is you can now
access TP use so previously you can
access GPUs and so this kind of i if you
want to play with things in the deep
learning space this would be a great
resource for that like to also plug next
month's beat up heidi to meet up and
who's going to be speaking it is you all
right so we're hosting our sort of
semiannual lightning talks
so it's coming from the community so
please go to the the meetup page and
sign up we think we have four speakers
right now there's room for maybe a
couple of more they're meant to be seven
minute unpolished dirty talk about
anything that you want yeah and yeah
please come out it's on Tuesday November
13 and in a minute I'm gonna welcome a
community announcements but there is one
from our friends over at crotale down on
Main Street so they have a talk with
Professor Jillian tang and the cut the
conversation will be about theory and
engineering of large e-commerce apps so
professor Tang is a working at Michigan
State University looking at generative
adversarial networks so very much
related to the talk that we had last
month
were there other community announcements
that anybody wanted to make either job
hires job postings maybe you're looking
for a job anybody hand up
was there one in the back what's your
name
Adam Adam to our chili is looking for
any position in particular okay
statistician anybody else right over
here Mike sniffles okay yeah so my name
is uni you I'm the first year
Universal regional study information
science and looking for an internship
this summer in business analysis
in both of the
great thank you
any other announcements great with that
I'd like to welcome our friends over at
the Ann Arbor our group Clayton Yocum
who is a regular here at I data they
juice our speaker for today yes so thank
you Sean yes so like you said this is a
joint meetup not only is this pi dating
Ann Arbor this is also the Ann Arbor our
user group why do recognize many faces
from thank you very much for coming out
and I would also like to encourage you
guys to come back to other PI data
meetups they are always doing very cool
stuff great content like you said I
think I've been to almost everyone since
they began I never regretted it so if
this is your first time here I know
you're gonna enjoy our talk today and I
hope you come back and to anyone that's
not familiar with the Ann Arbor our user
group find us on meetup.com we do host
regular meetups normally that would be
like this Thursday but we're doing this
instead and so if you are into our stuff
I encourage you to join us and I'm super
excited to to introduce our speaker dr.
Julia Sylvie she is the author of text
mining with data to the PI D data
principles and of the our package tidy
text which she'll be telling you a
little more about but I can recommend it
as being like the only good way to do
text analysis and are like wraps and
builds on top of took me like five hours
got nowhere and did all the same work in
like 20 minutes
using the tools that she's built she has
a PhD in astronomy from the University
of Texas Austin
she's a data scientist at Stack Overflow
she teaches courses through data camp on
both text mining and machine learning so
if you want to learn more about this
stuff
that's a great place to go and to
continue to hear it straight from Julia
and she's also a very pretty just
blogger and so you might be familiar
with some of her work on the Stack
Overflow blog she has talked about
things this year like their salary
calculator or analyzing the results of
their big developer survey that they do
every year and she also has her own
personal blog and her post just last
week was really good
it's called tensorflow Jane Austen and
text generation and she walks through
like a very introductory example of sort
of getting your feet wet using some of
these deep learning tool sorry keep
learning tools to to generate text so I
recommend checking that out and
hopefully she'll be
like addresses at some point and with
that I would like to welcome dr. Julia
Sylvia thank you so much for that for
that wonderful welcome I am so excited
to be here thank you all so much for
coming out this evening and thank you so
much to pie data and for the sponsors
for bringing me out this is very special
to be here I am so excited to be here
talking to you about text mining using
tiny data principles so I am as you
thank you so much that wonderful
introduction my name is Julia silly and
you can find me here on Twitter and here
is my website and what I do for my day
job is that I am a data scientist at
Stack Overflow so who here has heard of
Stack Overflow good okay if if no one
laughs it means I'm in the wrong room
giving like the wrong talk and it's
about to go very badly for me but so
that's good so I'm at Stack Overflow as
a like in my day job I work on mainly
two categories of questions and I do
statistical analysis and build machine
learning models and and one category is
about how sack overflow generates
revenue we we build products that help
companies engage with developers hire
developers companies that want to have
internal tools for developers to use so
how can i how can I use data to make all
that make all those products better and
more effective for our clients the other
category of things that I work on is
about the community of Stack Overflow
like the public Q&A community so for
example if someone comes to ask a
question how can we make that process
work better how can we scaffold someone
to success it how can we use the data we
have to understand when is this process
not working and when are people having
bad experiences how can we understand
how we can make sack or flow more
welcoming and more inclusive using the
data that we have both of these both of
these are obviously connected right
these are not like separate things that
are not connected to each other but both
of them involve dealing with text we
have a website where people come in like
they type they type in text and we and
we have to have to deal with that I have
to deal with this real world messy text
and I bet that this is true for a lot of
you that are sitting in this room here
with with me text data is increasingly
important in many of the domains that we
work in whether you work in healthcare
whether you work in finance whether you
work for a web a company like I do
people are writing product reviews
people are answering surveys text data
is being generated by all of these
processes around them and that text
contains in it information that you can
use to make your customers happier to
make your products better to make your
the things you're building more
equitable and more fair it's it's in
their latent but I'm sad to say that
often the the tools and the skills that
we need to get that day that decision
making information out those skills are
somewhat scarce on the ground
most of us were trained on like me you
know like like oh let's take this nice
rectangular-shaped data that has numbers
in it and let's like do some analysis on
it right like very few of us in here
probably have like advanced
computational linguistics training
instead instead we're thrown into it
we're like thrown into it were like oh
here's this text what are we going to do
what is it that we're going to do so the
what I want to make the point though the
the point I want to make to you tonight
is that using tiny data principles and
count based methods for dealing with
text makes text mining easier and more
effective and when I say easier what I
mean is easier to reason about and
easier to integrate your text mining and
natural language processing tasks in
- workflows that are already in wide use
in the data analysis community the data
science community and also that there's
a lot of support for already so this
talk and this work is based on a package
called tidy text so this is an R package
that's available on cran and that is
here on github that I'm the maintainer
and one of the authors of and we
recently have a sticker if you're a hex
ticker addict like I am I have them here
so if you would like one come get one
from me after the talk
so what tiny text offers is high-tech
text offers functions and supporting
data sets that act as a bridge as a link
between your text that you have your raw
text and the the tidy verse system of
tools it's height the tiny verse system
of tools that you have so that if you
want to be able to use ggplot2 for
visualization d ply or int IDR for data
manipulation broom for modeling if you
want to take all those tools and use
them with text then tidy text is what
allows us to have this bridge here so
Dave and I have together written a book
called text mining with our @id approach
and the book gives you tools for getting
started with this so at the end of this
you are ready to get going the book is
available in its entirety at Tidy text
mining comm also you can get paper
copies there they also have is a real
book that you can hold if you're
interested in getting one of those as
well so I've been standing up here
saying we should we should make our text
tidy we should make our text tidy what
do I mean what do I mean by that so the
important thing to think about when you
think about a tidy data structure is
that you should have one observation per
row so let's walk through that for a
very tiny little bit of text and see
what we mean by that let's take and the
first four lines of one of Emily
Dickinson's poems and let's convert it
let's let's tidy
let's transform it from this non tidy
form this is a character vector in R
this is like a set of strings and let's
convert it let's transform it let's tidy
it so let's we can load the tidy tex
package and then we can use the you can
put it into a data frame and then use
the function unnecessary have one
observation per row the observation here
that we're interested in is a single
word so before we read the poem across
we read the lines across now we're
reading down we have a long skinny data
frame instead of like a character vector
this wide notice a few things here other
columns that we that we have are still
around they've been retained so we still
know we still know which line each one
of these words came from we know that
these these first seven words came from
the first line and then we know that the
next ones start coming from the second
line we still know where every word came
from also there are some defaults like
the but the punctuation has been
stripped and words have been converted
to lowercase
these are defaults that are often useful
for next analytical steps but these can
these can be changed so this is a very
tiny little bit of text so what happens
if we do a slightly like a larger amount
well let's take the six published
completed novels of Jane Austen and
let's tidy those so this this will look
what might look something like this this
would be a tidy data structure for Jane
Austen's novels we might have some
columns like which book did this word
come from which line number is this on
like lying in the sense of reading
reading reading lines in a book which
chapter is this book is this word from
here so we know this for all four all of
these words here so this would be an
example of a tidy data structure for
Jane Austen's novels so this so here we
are we did it
we tidied our text it's very exciting I
know it's very
siding so you're sit you're sitting
there like what what have we like okay
Wells great why why are you why are you
talking to me about this okay
so the reason why this is an interesting
approach why this is an approach to
consider is that now that we have tidied
this now that we have tidied it there
are many things that we can do that are
that are easy to reason about and easy
to use standard tools that you can and
this is the reason to think about tidy
data in general not just for text when
you embrace tidy data principles then
you can use the same approach anytime
that you have the same kind of data set
you can always do the same thing you
have a standard set of of things that
where you can reason about the data that
you have so for example a common text
mining task is to remove stop words stop
words are words and for some analysis
that are not interesting they're super
common they're not interesting so here
these are from the snowball lexicon of
of stop words in English they're words
like I me myself we ours and so forth
and they're these are these are these
are just usually not interesting for
your analysis so we would want to get
rid of them in the tidy text package to
let you get these with a function called
get stock words you can get them for
other languages like here they are for
Portuguese you can get different sets of
them if they're if you want to for
example you want a bigger set you want
to take out more words versus taking out
fewer words if you want to remove stock
words from a from a set of text and you
have it in a tiny data set then you can
remove it via an anti join operation so
from from like a relational database
anti join so it's so in deep fire you
would do this you take your tiny data
structure you use an anti join with your
stock words data set and then after that
if we wanted to say okay what are what
are the most common words okay so we
we can use an anti join operation and
then once we have those words out we can
say what are the most common words using
deep liars count we just count them up
with sore equals true and we can make a
visualization that looks like this this
is answering the question what are the
most common words in Jane Austen's
novels once we take out once we remove a
soft word so it's words like mister
missus miss we see good time great we
see dear lady sir down there we see some
of the some of the proper names from
some of her longest from some of her
longest novels like Fanny and Emma so we
were able to get here like what are the
legends word frequencies what are the
most common words via just I mean like
I'm not very much code right like just a
couple lines of code because we embraced
high D data principles so and so that's
removing stock words another common
tasks that we want to do and we're test
mining is sentiment analysis so
sentiment analysis is saying okay we
have some text and I want to say what's
the emotional or or opinion content of
that text one approach a way to do this
is say okay I have a big amount of text
and I wanna I want it to say the the
total sentiment score is the is a sum of
the sentiment scores of all the words
that make that make up the text all
together
so the when you take that approach you
need a lexicon a dictionary I'll list as
it were a list of words that have been
pre scored so some score some lists are
scored like this where they're scored
from say this one is score from negative
5 to positive 5 words are either very
negative very positive some are scored
like this either this is the word is a
negative word this word is a positive
word some words are scored like some
some lexicons are scored like this where
this is a joy word this is a fear word
this is a sadness word and so forth also
people have built people that have built
domain-specific sentiment lexicons that
are built to work for specific kinds of
texts this
is built for the for the finance domain
so you can imagine what might happen if
you try to apply a general-purpose
sentiment lexicon to a financial
document I mean just take for example
the word share right like share in a in
a general-purpose lexicon is a positive
happy word right but in a in a fight in
a financial document that is a neutral
word that is a neutral word so there are
this is a these are all sentiment
lexicons that are included in the tidy
text package that are available there
and so this is one that you can use if
you have financial documents you can use
it to assess the the the sentiment the
in the in within the financial domain so
if we wanted to remove stock words we
use an anti join if you want in this if
you embrace tidy data principles you can
implement sentiment analysis using an
inner join using an inner join so if we
have our tidy data our jane austen here
in a tidy and tidy data structure and
when you do an inner join with one of
these with one of these sentiment
lexicons and then let's say let's let's
count up the sentiment scores in 100
lines and 100 line chunks of the book
and then find the net sentiment the
positive minus the negative that's what
these lines are doing and then if we
plot that we end up with a result like
this so we're able to see what is the
narrative arc of the story what is the
where in these stories are there a lot
of positive words being used and where
in the story are there a lot of negative
words being used these you know these
are a little noisy but these these ups
and these downs correspond to our human
readings and understanding of what's
going on in these stories
so probably the best-known one here is
Pride and Prejudice and if you look at
this section here about half way through
where there's a section of extended
negative sentiment that's where mr.
Darcy proposes
for the first time so insultingly and
elizabeth is so angry and it goes very
badly and then this section about 3/4 of
the way through that's where Lydia
elopes with mr. Wickham and it's a
terrible scandal so so we're like we
like we're measuring real events that
happen in these books when we when we
measure sentiment in this way we're able
to were able to get to these kinds of
insights using these tidy data
principles here one thing that's very
important when you do sentiment analysis
of any kind is to interrogate which
words contribute to each sentiment if
you're doing a deep learning approach to
sentiment analysis that can this can be
difficult because you have to do a fair
amount of extra work to get at this with
a tiny data approach is very easy it's
very easy to get at this it's literally
just counting with two arguments instead
of counting with one argument the reason
why you want to know this the reason why
that you want to understand which words
are contributing to your sentiment your
sentiment scores is because your
sentiment lexicons are not always a
perfect match
for the text that you're studying this
problem does not go away with deep
learning approaches a sentiment analysis
the way the sentiments models were
trained may not be a perfect match to
the text that you're dealing with you
need to look at these if you want to use
a tidy data approach to send them an
analysis you can look at something like
this and then look at something like
this and you can say okay how good am i
doing how good am i doing you can say
okay well let's look at the positive
side we've got well good great like
better enough happy things are looking
good looks like I did good on the
positive side let's look at the negative
side well we've got poor doubt object
sorry
impossible afraid those all sound sad
those all sound like bad words
but let's look at that top word miss
miss first of all look how much more
it's used than any other negative word
it's the biggest driver of negative
sentiment score what did Jane Austen use
the word miss for in her books a young
lady it's a it's a it's a title it's a
title of a young unmarried woman that's
not a negative word that's a neutral
word that's a neutral word when we used
Tidy data principles it was not hard to
find this it was not hard to find this I
have good news it's also not hard to fix
this it's also not hard to fix this
problem all we have to do is take that
word miss out of our lexicon we it's a
mutual word for this text take it out of
our sentiment lexicon go back use a
sentiment analysis again problem solved
problem solved all right that's the
third topic I would like to talk about
is how do we programmatically get at
what a document is about so we're going
to talk about tf-idf so the first part
part of that stands for term frequency
term frequency means how often does a
document use a word and the second part
is inverse document frequency which is a
weight and the weight works like this
it applies to documents in a collection
of documents so think about it as like a
whole bunch of webpages or a whole bunch
of books or some collection of documents
you want to take let's say so let's say
think about that all those documents
let's say they all contain the word V
then this ratio is one the natural log
of one is zero and so that weight is
down that would gather that that weight
goes down let's think about our
documents again let's say only one or
two of them contain some word the rest
of them don't contain it
that means this ratio is AB is a bigger
number the natural log is not zero it's
a bigger number so then that weight will
go up if you take TF term frequency
times IDF you get tf-idf so that's a
statistic it's a statistic a thing we
measure
a thing we measure it's a heuristic
quantity it has no theoretical
underpinning it's been very successful
in like internet search it has it
performs very well so it's really good
for understanding documents in a
collection of documents so let's work
through this tf-idf also lends itself
very well to tidy data principles of
being calculated via tiny data
principles so we can use some text like
this to calculate a data frame that
looks like so where we say okay for
every book how for every book in word
how many times does it use that word and
then how many words is the book have
total we see here which are the longest
books we see here the the usual suspects
for English write these very exciting
meaningful words that were really
excited to analyze and we can make a
graph that looks like this so this is
just term frequency so there are very
few words that are used a lot so these
are like the nd of - way out here and
then there are lots of words that are
only used very few times so these kind
of distributions are very common in
natural language so common they have a
special name it's called zips la zi PF
zips law if you plot it on a log-log
scale it's like close to a straight line
so this is term frequency then we can
calculate tf-idf so the tidy tex package
has a a function called bind tf-idf and
we use it here we can find TF which is
just exactly the same as that term
frequency we found before and then IDF
which here is zero because all six of
Jane Austen's novels contain these words
because she wrote in English and then we
multiply these two numbers together and
we get zero right this is this is some
thrilling stuff here that I am showing
you but instead let's take this data
frame and let's arrange it let's sort it
so that we see the highest
FIF words so the highest tf-idf words
are these words and in fact we can make
a little visualization here if you're
familiar with Jane Austen's novels then
you know who these people and places are
but even if you don't care about Jane
Austen
at all I'm sorry that you're here but um
you know if you don't care at all then
you know these are proper names right
you can tell that these are proper names
these are the names of people and places
so let's set back for a minute and ask
what does this mean what does this mean
this means that Jane Austen used like
like consistent language from one book
to the other and the things that are
most distinctive about one book compared
to the other books are the names of the
people and the places that's what makes
one book the most different from the
other books that's what tf-idf measures
that's what it measures so um it does
not have to be applied to several
hundred year old narrative texts it is a
powerful technique that can be applied
to to to many different kinds of texts
and including short text we did it to
like a like a novel at a time here but
you can apply it to like like like like
tweet length text like the there it's a
very it's a powerful and flexible
technique that takes advantage of the
flexibility of Tidy data principles as
well so so far so far I've been talking
to you about single words I've been
saying one observation per row and in
every row there's been a single word but
it does not have to be that way it does
not have to be that way if the the
analytical question that you want to ask
involves engrams that can be your
observation your one observation
perrault a by an in graham is any group
of n words so a bigram is a group of two
words trigram is a group of three words
and you can analyte you can tokenize
two engrams using tidy de hex you can do
many different kinds of tokenization
using tidy text including and gram
tokenization and then a enormous world
of analytical possibilities are open to
you for example one example you can see
in the book is to look at networks of
words which words co-occur together more
which words are more likely to occur
together than not you can look at
negation you you can get at so for
example the sentiment analysis approach
that we talked about which is sometimes
called bag-of-words sentiment analysis
does not take into account negation it
looks at the sentence this is not good
and it's like I don't know use the word
good I guess that's really good sentence
or whatever so you can use N Grant by
Gram analysis with a negation words and
you can you can measure for your text
how often are you getting it wrong and
use that to understand like to put
uncertainty on your measure of your
sentiment analysis one analysis I did
that I that I love as a example of the
power of these kinds of in EM these
Engram analyses is to look to take Jane
Austen's novels and to find all the the
by grams that have he or she in the
first the first space and then look at
what comes in the second space and to
look for differences between what is
more likely to come after she verses one
is more likely to come after he so in
Jane Austen's novels women are more
likely to remember read feel resolved
long hear dare cry men are more likely
to stop take reply come Mary scene so we
see here that we see here evidence for
how much Jane Austen's novels are about
the internal lives of women like it's
about like what women think and feel and
the male the the men the verbs
associated with the men are very much
about like actions and kind of
like what they're doing because because
it's not about the internal lives of men
like that's not what she's writing about
so we can understand here like how an
author handles gender by doing this kind
of text mining analysis I was able to
extend this analysis with by partnering
with the data visualization data love
journalism experts at the pudding on
this project called um she giggles he
gallops so they have a large data set of
film scripts and what we did was we took
the film scripts and we scraped out the
we removed we removed the the dialogue
so that all that was less left was the
set direction so this is this is the
part of the scripts that tells the
actors what to do like what actions to
take what you know facial expressions to
have and all this kind of things and
then I repeated the same kind of
analysis what are what is more likely to
come after he and what is more likely to
come after she so we see here like she
snuggles giggles squeals sobs weeps and
then we and then we see here things in
the middle the things that are eat very
equally likely to come after men and
women or like for he and she like waits
gets chooses obviously takes decides
these are things that are even and then
the things that are more likely to come
after he so it's things like honks rams
releases clears prized shoots like these
are the things that are more likely to
come after heat so what I love about
this example is it shows how we can take
this text mining analysis and use it to
explore what are the stories that were
telling ourselves about who we are we're
able to understand use these kinds of
tools that we're building that I use in
my day job like to help stackoverflow be
a thriving place and actually use it to
understand like like what is our like
what is our cultural perception and do
we want it to be that way and what can
we do to what what can we
do in the kind of media that we choose
to to take in so I have been here up
here preaching the gospel of tidy data
I've been saying tidy data everyone it
is so good and so important but it turns
out text data does not need to be or
perhaps it does not always should should
not always be in a tidy data structure
in fact sometimes it's really great to
have data in a matrix so that you can do
math on it turns out it's just real
that's really helpful sometimes so we
talked about the this transformation
back and forth in terms of the verbs
tidying and casting so tidying is the
verb we mean to say to go to a tidy data
structure and casting is the verb to go
to a non tidy data structure and non
tiny doesn't mean bad or messy it just
means like not one observation per row
and that kind of data frame that we've
been talking about so for example a
document term matrix would be an example
of a non tiny data structure for text so
you might end up with some kind of a a
workflow that looks like this where we
have our like your raw text data over
there
where it says text data you can make it
go to we use unless tokens to go to tiny
text you can do EDA here with like your
summarized text and and gain a lot of
insight here but one thing you can do
from the summarized text is you can go
down here to a document term matrix and
once you have a document term matrix you
can build models you can do some a great
variety of kinds of machine learning
algorithm on a document term matrix and
then once you have your document term
matrix you you we in tidy text have
support for tidying the output of those
because often the people who have
implemented these machine learning
algorithms often giving you give you
those outputs as he's like
three objects that are not so convenient
in my opinion to work with and so we
will tidy them for you so that you have
a data frame at the end and then you can
use D plier tidy our ggplot2 to the to
make visualizations of what you have at
the end so um so one example here is
topic modeling so topic modeling is
unsupervised machine learning method for
saying okay I have a hole I have this
text I believe there are latent topics
in it I think something's going on in
here and I want to find out what they
are so I have a blog post on the stack
overflow ba blog about topic modeling of
Stack Overflow questions and it's a it's
a very interesting result because we did
not tell the topic modeling procedure
about the tags about the sack overflow
tags but the topic modeling procedure
grouped questions with related tags
together so for example topic 1 up there
who that got real small I apologize for
that okay so topic 1 is CSS HTML jQuery
JavaScript like those are front-end web
technologies topic 4 here is sequel my
sequel a sequel server c-sharp and
Oracle so we got like like sequel things
all together we topic 12 down here is
iOS objective-c iPhone Swift like these
are these are Apple mobile technologies
so the the topic model learned the
underlying latent topics in stack
overflow questions if you're interested
in getting started with topic modeling
and are using this kind of approach I
have a I have a blog post and a YouTube
video tutorial for getting started with
the SCM package which is my current
favorite implementation of topic
modeling at our it is written in C++
it's fast easy to install works really
well and you we also are able to address
questions like like how many
the topic should you pick for K like
what what is the appropriate number of
topics for any given corpus so often
you'll see you'll see approaches that
have a little baby toy datasets and
you're like we know you know like I
order fish aliy put like four things in
there so we know it's like the you know
like doing k-means on the iris dataset
right like we got three you know like
good for us so I have I have a blog post
of like how we using a realistic data
set how do we decide okay how do we
decide the number of topics in this kind
of unsupervised machine learning
approach and so look so here for example
so this is about how well did the this
is about how well did the model converge
semantic coherence measures is a is a
measure of how how much do the words in
the topic mean the same thing and it
always goes down in this way you just
want to see like is there some kind of a
bend in it or whatever but then over
here this is with you if you make held
out data sets what what is the
likelihood for when you fit the model
the model you fit on the full data set
how does it do on like held out out data
sets and then this is residual so here
we want residuals to be low we want
likely to be high so this one is very
nice it's like pretty clear where we
want to be for K for this kind of data
set so we can look at that there and
then we're gonna end the last thing that
we're going to talk about tonight is
text classification so we've gone we
started it like counting things counting
and we're gonna we were going through
unsupervised we went through tf-idf
sentiment analysis a little bit of
unsupervised learning we're an end with
supervised supervised machine learning
some text classification here so we
started with some some Emily Dickinson
some Jane Austen and we're gonna we're
gonna end with a combo a combo of our
friend HG Wells here and
in Austin and we're gonna walk through
how you would a train a GLM net model
which is regularized regression a
regular eyes drew Gresham model and
we're gonna see we're gonna walk through
how well get her how would you train a
model to tell the difference between
private prejudice and War of the Worlds
so so the way that this is trained is
it's trained line by line so it's like
you take each of the books and you chop
them all up if you chop them up into
single lines and then train it using
cross-validation and then and then I
probably I don't think I included I have
a in process blog post of how to do like
ROC a you see all that business to see
like how is it matter how well it does
um well so let's walk through this so
here we go yeah okay okay so if we take
a we take our tiny data set we count
them up we summarize it and then we cast
to a sparse matrix so this is really
great and I have found this to be very
useful in my real life day job on this
approach of using sparse matrices and
GLM that has been very very effective in
my actual real life day job for if I
need to train some kind of text
classification model so our does not
have a native sparse matrix type but
they have implementations of it in the
capital M matrix package so you can use
that to create this data to this sparse
matrix and then we're going to make a
data frame here that is going to tell us
okay with the row names which is going
to tell us the document number I need to
know I need to know the title I need to
know the title for each one of these
guys however you made the sparse matrix
I need to know which which which book
did it come from did it come from War of
the Worlds
or did it come from Pride and Prejudice
and then we can load up the GLM net
package and the GLM that package is I
would say actually my workhorse when it
- - like supervised machine learning and
like what I need to do when it's like
when it's when it's like it's time to
get down to it like what I'm gonna do
and we can use take advantage of
parallel processing here we're going to
find a mega response variable this is
the Y the Y variable that we're gonna
predict I'm calling it is Jane so this
is a true/false it's a logical vector
when it's when it's the Pride and
Prejudice it's true when it's War of the
Worlds it's false so we have a whole
bunch of true-false true-false
true-false and then we can with
cross-validation predict our train a
model here train on our sparse matrix
our sparse matrix is the response the X
is Jane is the Y and here I'm going to
train a binomial the family equals
binomial I'm so I'm gonna I'm gonna
retain logistic regression a logistic
regression model here and then because
the output of GL m-net is not not really
what I want to deal with I want to deal
with a dataframe
I'm going to use Broome I'm gonna tidy
the output so notice I started with
something tidy
I cast I did my machine learning and now
I'm gonna tidy what I have here at the
as the output so that I can so that I
can get out the output here I'm going to
choose so regularize drew Gresh in it
tries a whole bunch of lambdas like it
tries a whole bunch of values for the
regularization parameter and so here I'm
going to pick the one that minimized the
error the one that mineralised the
cross-validation error here and then I'm
gonna say okay find my intercept there
and then I can make a plot that looks
like this so these are the coefficients
that increase or decrease the
probability of the classification so wit
so remember what were my what was I
training on a sparse matrix of words
that was what was that's what I was
training on so the these
blue bars those are the ones that
increase the likelihood of something
being written from coming from Pride and
Prejudice and these here and the red
bars are the things that decrease the
likelihood of it coming from there so
things that mention Elizabeth Longbourn
family Kitty Meriton Wickham letter Jane
and she these are all things that are
more likely coming from Jane Austen and
Martians smoke heat cylinders black pits
or red red pits these are things that
are more likely to be coming from War of
the Worlds so so this is um this is some
of the output that we get from from the
output that we get from this GLM that
model so like if you're interested in
this kind of approach you can of course
like use this and get started yourself
but you can look for I'm working on a
blog post about how to start from here
and then calculate on Roc on auc be able
to do all the other supervised machine
learning things that we have there so as
I sum up here's what I want to emphasize
we went through a lot of text mining
things that we want to be able to do we
talked about tf-idf we talked about
sentiment analysis we talked about
unsupervised machine learning supervised
machine learning we went through a lot
of content really fast there are
resources out there from me and for
others about how to implement the
details of any of these things like blog
posts my our book what I want you to
take away from this tonight is that tiny
data principles make these things make
push can push you to fluency to to being
able to take the text you have and being
able to take that step to be able to
moving forward with that and with that
I'll say thank you
we have time for a few questions but I
will ask you that please phrase your
question in the form of questions rather
than a statement or a comment we do
welcome you do you know provide comments
afterwards - that would be lovely and I
do have I do have stickers if you would
like a sticker so this question was
about stemming and because I didn't
mention stemming and like how how would
I approach stemming so there are some
packages out there for stemming and are
that's your if that's your preferred
workflow there also are some very
interesting academic papers about the
dangers of stemming are you all ready to
hear about it
okay so stemming people just like oh
yeah default time to stem time to go
about my business and stem my words but
the people the academics who study this
have shown that when you stem words you
um you you reduce the so for example in
topic this has been studied pretty well
in topic modeling if you stem your words
before you do your topic modeling you
reduce the coherence you reduce
basically everything good you can
measure about your topic goes down and
and anything good it doesn't get any
better you you basically there's no at
the best at best
stemming doesn't hurt you at worst
stemming has a negative effect on your
topic modeling so if you want to Google
this for yourself the look at the work
of David MIM know there's a there's a
great paper called I'm comparing apples
to apples that's the title of it it is
wonderful and it bees very rigorous and
shows like what is the effect of
stemming the I mean if you want to think
about it basically if you if you have a
enough data like if you have enough data
to get the signal out it doesn't it will
just put those in the topic together or
will just if you're doing supervision
supervised learning and we'll just put
those together like it will it will it
the algorithm will if they belong
together they will go together if they
if you force it if you force it together
by stemming and it didn't really belong
together then you're hurting yourself so
that's that's if you want to think about
it conceptually that's the basic basic
idea okay
so limited ation I haven't seen as much
detailed work on it yet like detailed
academic work on it yet yes yes yes yeah
so it put Martian and Martians together
is that bad no no the algorithm knew to
do that nothing went wrong it puts them
together nothing is wrong nothing
happened wrong it at best stemming
doesn't hurt you but it can't like it
can't hurt you it does not improve does
not mean so it doesn't so it doesn't
improve the anything you can measure
about the in performance or the the the
characteristic of your topic modeling or
whatever so it is possible for your
dataset it might so this is something
that if you're like training supervised
models you should try it both ways and
do whichever one works better right it's
but it's not a guarantee that stemming
is going to help you so it should not be
a default choice because because it may
not in fact it has been shown that it's
often just not
is there a certain type of file you use
that retains as my numbers arbitrarily
assign numbers is there another way
right now so this question was about and
the sentiment analysis plots that where
you could see like the narrative
structure and I divided them into a
hundred line chunks in that section that
plot pushed put together a hundred line
chunks I've made multiple versions of
that plot since we started the book with
like seventy line chunks 80 line chunks
it ends up being like a issue of
signal-to-noise like how many it's a
smoothing it's a smoothing factor
effectively I mean if you want to know
the details of like what does a line
mean there a line is how how is that
text encoded by Project Gutenberg what
are they calling what are they calling a
line when they encode that book so it's
a it's a it's a smoothing factor and so
that is a that is a art not science
issue there you know when you're saying
like what should we do to make a issue
there and actually there's some very
interesting academic research on this
issue because you may have seen this
actually like making the rounds like
there's only six kinds of stories
everyone like you may have seen this go
around like they took you know like a
hundred thousand novels and then they
did that kind of thing they very very
close to what I did and then they fit
smooth lines to it and that how smooth
the lines are is a parameter in that and
so depending on how smooth you want to
make your friends makes a difference in
like how many stories you want to say
there are in the world and and also
people have done things like Fourier
transforms of that but but a free a
transform always like a low-pass Fourier
transform always begins and ends at the
same amplitude so it's like what do you
do you know like so so these are
I'm not saying these are bad approaches
but I'm saying they're they're
parameterize approaches and the
parameters you choose affect the output
you guess you need so if you were to
take them you need to think about how
robust is the conclusion that I'm coming
to how robust is it to the decisions I'm
making so where do you think we are in
terms of getting to that so this
question was about state of the art deep
learning for natural law natural
language processing like transfer
learning for natural language processing
do like do we think like is this is the
future here is it here now are we having
this now so first of all I am actually
very interested in this because there
are there so I showed you this GLM net
model and I've had a lot of success for
example in my like in my real day job
using this to predict something like for
example how senior a developer is based
on things they type in in or you know
like stuff like this but when you get to
more if you want to take text and you
want to learn or you want to predict
something that is embedded more subtly
then using word counts will probably not
get you there right like using word
counts is not going to get you to more
subtly encoded semantic meaning I'm
interested this in this for example when
it comes to trying to understand snark
and unfriendliness on Stack Overflow
right like like is where our word counts
gonna get me there only for like
extremely offensive words right and
that's not really sack overflows main
problem is extremely offensive words so
so I think that this is an area that is
prom
seeing and interesting these deep
learning approaches they are interesting
I think for a different category of
problems then some that you might use
here and they have different pros and
cons for example one big con is if you
start with a existing pre trained model
like say some set of word embeddings or
or even some like existing pre-trained
classifier and you're just gonna like
lay on your like frosting of sprinkle on
your like a little bit of data on the
top for transfer learning those are our
pre trained on large a large corpus of
data from somewhere and that is those
have very impactful biases in written
into them for example if you train a
sentiment analysis classifier using like
like some of these very big prominent
data sets that are used for these like
like the Google News dataset or like
that's the one I think I've seen the the
biggest problems with if you if you send
them if you train a deep learning
sentiment analysis predict predictor
like a classifier you end up with things
like very simple sentences being having
being predicted as like negative
sentiment when they just use very simple
very simple names or words that are that
that are have have racial identity you
know like you have someone using a like
like let's let's go get Italian food
being very positive and let's go get
Chinese food like mildly negative and
let's go get Mexican food classified is
very very negative if you train these
classifiers that's what happens when you
use these large corpuses because the way
people have used language in the corpus
affects your model and and is this
something there are people are working
on like ways to get around this what are
we going to do
if you start if you start with something
existing that is black boxy these like
these are the important issues you need
to be aware of so that's all the time
that we have today but I encourage
everybody to come up see hello
grab a sticker and I also want to
encourage everybody to grab Juliet book
as well let's give Julia random apart
[Applause]